you know i can remember speaking of
being in high school
uh the bullies that i went to school
with
you know the real life schoolyard bully
was never quite as one-dimensional and
cartoonishly villainous as he was
portrayed in shows and movies that we
watched back then but he was still a
jerk right and as i recall bullies were
pretty straightforward they would impose
themselves on those who were weaker
and taunt and belittle them
because it gave them the bullies
personal satisfaction and probably
because they were trying to assuage
their own damaged egos and enhance their
own sense of self-worth and so on
but the message from the bully was
i'm strong
you're weak
and that makes me better than you
the bully would try to hurt his victim's
feelings or hurt him physically and if
he succeeded then he won at least in his
mind
that's why the best response to a bully
back then was to try to beat him at his
own game to cause him the exact sort of
hurt that he wanted to cause you if you
succeeded then the bully was vanquished
at least for a time if you punched the
bully in the nose and made him run off
crying
then you won because you had asserted
your dominance over him
he had made a fool of himself and cried
in front of everybody and this was a
source of shame
that's the way that it used to work it
wasn't it wasn't great
it wasn't a great position to be in
bullying is never a good thing
it was a little bit messy at times
but i have to say lately i've been
pining for the simplicity and the
coherence of those days how bullying
used to work
because now things are flipped on their
head the bullies are all
you know sort of modeling themselves
after that scene in fight club where uh
edward norton gets revenge on his boss
by beating the hell out of himself in
the boss's office
so the bully now
asserts his dominance assuages his ego
enhances his own self-worth
by manufacturing ways in which he has
been hurt by his victim
bullying today is far more
passive-aggressive
manipulative
and psychologically twisted than the
simple days of you know calling somebody
a name shoving them into a locker to let
them know that you're more powerful than
them
now the bullies assert their power
by pretending that their victim is
asserting power over them
they gain power by affecting
powerlessness
when i was younger it would have been
embarrassing for anyone especially a guy
to admit that he had his feelings hurt
now there's a contest over who had their
feelings hurt the most
you know it used to be if you said i got
my feelings hurt everybody would point
and laugh at you you got your feelings
are you a loser
now instead of responding that way
everybody says no no i have my feelings
hurt even more than you
neither response is great
but what we're doing now is worse
this is how modern cancer culture works
of course
we saw a perfect example of this over
the weekend when a guy by the name of
frederick joseph who's a black man and
also an author and i'll tell you more
about his book in a moment because it is
relevant here
he sent out a string of tweets claiming
that he had been accosted by a white
woman in a dog park in brooklyn
he tweeted quote at the dog park in
brooklyn with my fiance and this white
woman was threatening to call police and
told us to stay in our hood because she
had our dog confused with another dog
who had been barking loudly so i started
recording and she tried to slap the
phone out of my hand
he then posted the video of course but
but naturally the video cuts on right
after all of this allegedly happened
let's watch it here check it out
in our hood no no no no no no no no no
inside everyone stay in our
stay in our hood that's what i'm sorry
what
stay in our hood
stay in our hood you just told us to
stay
i'm sorry you were right here watch this
entire thing did she just not stand here
tell us to stay in our hood she did she
just you just told us
so what do we know from that video um
well nothing at all we don't know the
context
we don't know what was said before the
video cuts on
we don't know what precipitated the
interaction or even what the interaction
was
we don't know if she said what he
claimed she said or why she said it if
she did if she did in fact say anything
we don't know anything
we have only this out of context video
featuring a group of people that none of
us have ever heard of
and we have the word of mr frederick
joseph
a word which
must be taken with a rather large
portion of salt given that frederick
joseph is the author of a book called
the black friend on being a better white
person
on being a better white person
now i don't need to read the book to
know that it's a racist screed for the
same reason that frederick joseph
wouldn't have to read a book by me about
being a better black person to declare
that it's racist
so this guy is a professional race
baiter
who's in the business of telling white
people how to be better
and he just so happens to find himself
in this situation with an allegedly
racist white woman
you might almost think that this
anti-white race-baiting bigot may have
engineered this situation to play out
exactly as it did who knows
but joseph wasn't satisfied to simply
put the video up and leave it at that of
course he then proceeds to dig up this
woman's name
and other pictures of her and post them
online also
he even posts the name of her dog for
some reason
he uh posts the the town where she lives
and then he finds out where she works or
worked i should say and he posts that
information and then he personally
contacts her boss by the name of derrick
anderson at a company called bevy to try
and get her fired
and obviously he succeeds
so within hours of the original out of
context 15 second video being posted
the woman has lost her job
lost her reputation her privacy
probably most of her friends given where
she lives
derek anderson her former boss tweeted
this
uh bevy has zero tolerance for
discriminatory behavior of any kind
yesterday an employee engaged in
behavior contrary to our values and has
been terminated we apologize deeply to
all involved
now how does he know what sort of
behavior she engaged in
there couldn't have been enough time to
actually investigate the situation
thoroughly
we don't know
but that doesn't matter all he knows is
that frederick joseph says that his
feelings were hurt and that's all the
information he needs
now for his part for his part after
randomly ruining this stranger's life
for no reason
frederick joseph posted a follow-up
video encouraging everybody white people
namely to uh learn the right lessons
from this incident watch this
so i was just told um that bevy
has terminated emma sarley after her
racist attack against my fiance and i in
the dog park and while it's unfortunate
um that she had to lose her job um i do
think that this brings up an important
conversation about uh accountability um
especially in a country where um black
and brown people marginalize people as a
whole have seen so little of it um often
times right um you know having to bear
the burden of racism sexism homophobia
etc um i think that it's important that
people know that there are consequences
uh for their actions right and i don't
think that it's um up to victims to have
to coddle um you know people who are
engaging in abuse
um you know when i woke up yesterday
morning
i didn't expect to have to be a part of
this um conversation um i didn't expect
to go to the dog park as a black person
um and
have to receive um you know racism uh
you know so while again it is
unfortunate what happened i hope that
you know emma learns from this i hope
that um other people learn from this who
engage in abusive racist um
and destructive behavior because
ultimately um whether emma lost her job
or not doesn't take away the trauma that
my fiance and i have it doesn't take
away
the feeling of
feeling like anything racist can happen
anywhere so
i don't think that people should be
coddled and i do think that consequences
are important so hopefully this is a
learning lesson for everybody
a learning lesson
so the rule maintains here the rule i've
told you about anytime someone says
they've done or said something in order
to start a conversation they're always
full of it 100 of the time and here yet
again well it brings up an important
conversation it's unfortunate she had to
lose her job she had to lose her job
it's unfortunate
after i have deliberately
made sure that she loses her job after i
spent my weekend
trying to make sure that this woman lost
her job
it's unfortunate that it happened it had
to happen
it's just how the stars aligned you know
it's fate what could i do about
it well it turns out i could do a lot to
make sure she loses her job because
that's what i spent my weekend doing
he says he was traumatized
he's traumatized by this little white
woman at a dog park
when
when i was a kid
you know if a guy had had claimed to
have been traumatized
by by words that someone else had said
much less of words that a girl has said
to you
you'd be mocked ruthlessly
then you're going to suffer real trauma
that that's that's the kind of social
sin
in going around saying i was traumatized
by those words you said to me
that would stay with you forever
you know if you said that in third grade
ten years later people would still be
talking about it making fun of you for
it
but this is how bullying works now
this is the this is the
the power of victimhood
the bully
asserts his power by affecting
powerlessness claiming that he is the
one who is traumatized
while he at least tries to cause trauma
to other people
i would say that's that's real trauma
when you
when you have the the internet lynch mob
coming after you you lose your job and
everything else
and i say all this knowing by the way
that
this this woman um
i'm going to assume a pretty good chance
that she is a leftist herself given
where just based on where she lives
alone
and and so you might say this is another
example of the left eating its own
perhaps so
but it's still a problem because it's
yet again the bully
asserting the power of victimhood
it's just not possible to have a
functioning society this way
it was one thing when the strong used to
subjugate the weak by imposing their
strength
now they subjugate the weak by
pretending to be weaker
which in the end we find out is a
much worse situation
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content